storia che nasce
dovrei andare
tutti con
ok
una storia che nasce con questa macchina
per cucire una macchina per cucire
singer del 1906 una macchina per cucire
singer nel 1906 questa macchina
accompagna ancora i nostri giorni le
nostre giornate lavorative e quindi
lavora con noi è una macchina che
funziona a pedali quindi aziona le
articolazioni quindi non non consuma
energia quindi ad impatto zero e
accarezza i tessuti perché con la sua
cadenza molto ma molto ma molto lenta
luce in maniera perfetta rispetto alle
macchine industriali nasce con questa
macchina e nasce con mia nonna una donna
una donna tenace una donna coraggiosa
che rimasta vedova con quattro figli
inizia a produrre camicie a ginosa tanti
anni fa il mio bisnonno l'aiutava e si
spostava negli stati uniti per portargli
per portarle delle fodere l'interno per
i colli quindi lei con questi materiali
inizia questa avventura questa avventura
che è una sartoria che dopo che dopo un
po di anni
continua continua con i miei zii ecco io
guardo guardo questa foto è in questa
foto vedo vedo i miei zii vedo il mio
papà ma vedo anche tanti apprendisti
vedo questa questo ambiente magico che
era quello della bottega in bottega in
bottega tutti si tutti gli apprendisti
si formavano vivevano questo questa
situazione
questa situazione familiare ecco
vivevano questa questa vocazione si
capiva la vocazione poi questa magia
purtroppo con gli anni è stata
interrotta è stata interrotta da chi
e stata interrotta dalla grande
industria è arrivata la grande industria
è arrivata l'ilva nella nostra zona ha
promesso a tutti questi apprendisti la
ambita l'ambita scalata sociale ecco
quindi quindi si è perso un po di questo
di questa magia io la chiamo maggio e
l'ambiente bottegal è per me una magia è
una magia che io vorrei ancora
ricostruire io sono molto appassionato
ecco quindi vorrei ricostruire ancora
questo ambiente ma ve ne parlerò dopo
quindi dopo questa dopo questa dopo che
la sartoria era andata avanti per tanti
anni ed aveva perso ed aveva perso un po
la fiducia avevano perso un po tutti la
fiducia si arriva alla si arriva che io
prendo in mano
prendo in mano questa attività prendo in
mano questa attività che sinceramente
l'unico intento che avevo era quello di
fare un prodotto dico di riprendere un
po quello che faceva mia nonna quindi di
continuare a 15 anni fa la prendo in
mano continua a fare questo prodotto
tradizionale
quindi questo prodotto tradizionale che
doveva
è l'unico impegno ecco che io mi ero
che mi condizionava era quello di fare
questo prodotto di internazionalizzare
lo ma non di di non lasciare mai g9 di
non lasciare mai ginosa perché io sono
molto ma molto legato al territorio
individuo come mercato di riferimento il
giappone perché il giappone perché il
giappone
a gente straordinaria il giappone a
agente è molto ma molto legata alla
cultura nostra la cultura della nostra
sartoria ma al nostro saper vivere
italiano loro quando vengono in visita
da noi a ginosa noi che abbiamo un
territorio che è molto simile a quello
di matera guardano queste grotte ed
immaginano il senso della famiglia loro
loro hanno pochissimi anni di storia
quindi ci invidiano per questo è quindi
il giapponese erano dei grandi
estimatori allora cosa ho iniziato a
fare
ho iniziato a fare dei piccoli video
della lavorazione della camicia ma la
cosa che è lì o inviati gli inviati in
giappone l'inviato di notte 15 anni fa
il web era lentissimo solo di notte era
possibile far arrivare questi video in
giappone altrimenti a di giorno ti
cadeva la linea e non ce la facevo più
di notte a volte che aveva la linea e
per e dovevi riprova la notte successiva
perché ci voleva una notte intera per
far arrivare 8 secondi di video ma la
cosa che è piaciuta in modo particolare
giapponesi è stata la sla ecco questa
isola qui io devo parlarvi di questa
sola perché ha delle peculiarità e delle
particolarità uniche a più di 20 7
passaggi di ricamo al lato
loro sono stati attratti da questa cosa
mi hanno subito fissato un appuntamento
mi hanno chiesto di vedermi a pitti uomo
maria pitti uomo non ci poteva andare
non mi accettavano vero piccolo erano
non oggi vado oggi ma allora non potevo
andarci
e allora dietro loro suggerimento fisso
un appuntamento con loro in un albergo a
un attimo soltanto che vi illustra ecco
fissa un appuntamento valori non albergo
adiacente alla fortezza da basso sede
espositiva di pitti uomo in questa in
questa sede
mi fanno diversi ordini mi fanno diversi
ordini e mi ordinano vi devo dire
senza che loro abbiano provato la mia
vestibilità perché la vestibilità
giapponese è diversa da quella europea e
quindi mi ordinano aspettando solo un
contro campione io ricevo questi ordini
dopo che ricevo questi ordini mi metto
mi metto a lavorare sul serio perché
tutti mi dicevano che mi consigliava di
lavorare con il giappone mi diceva
guarda che loro sono bravi comprano
apprezzano il prodotto però devi essere
molto ma molto ligio al dovere allora mi
metto a lavorare con loro e le nostre
camicie in giappone diventano popolari
diventano popolari e iniziano ad essere
indossate da gente dello spettacolo
iniziano ad essere indossate da da
attori iniziano ad essere indossate da
politici ed è proprio di questo politico
che io vi vorrei parlare spero di
trovarlo subito eccolo qui questo è un
politico
questo è stato primo ministro in
giappone
diversi anni fa si chiama yukio a toyama
questo signore qui nostro cliente da
sempre in una comparsa pubblica indossa
questa camicia buffa improponibile
chiamiamola perché i giornalisti che
hanno dato hanno dato tantissime
definizioni e questa camicia ammette
mette su questa camicia mette su questa
camicia e
la stampa la stampa sapendo che lui si
forniva da noi che io gli facevo le
camicie inizia a chiedersi lo chiamano
subito e un fashion disaster punto
interrogativo è una caduta di stile non
si sa non riuscivano ad avere una
risposta da lui iniziarono ad
intervistare me ho fatto due giorni e
mezzo di interviste di continuo
in tutto questo in tutto questo tempo ho
spiegato ho spiegato che io al primo
ministro
realizza realizzo perché tuttora il mio
cliente realizzo camicie con i criteri
di sartoria quindi diversi da questo
modello qui che mi sembrava una camicia
americana ma una camicia degli anni 80
tra l'altro con le spalle molto basse
quindi ma non riuscivamo a canti a
capire come mai l'avesse indossata ecco
nelle interviste mi chiedevano ma tu
conosci sai se potrebbe essere una
caduta di stile
dicevo no perché il primo ministro
proviene da una famiglia nobile quindi
il papa il papa era stato ministro della
repubblica il suo zio primo ministro
la mamma era una discendente dei
bridgestone e mi sembrava non mi sembra
una cosa normale poi alla fine abbiamo
scoperto dopo le sue dimissioni abbiamo
scoperto che lui stava perdendo
popolarità quindi aveva indossato questa
camicia perché perdeva popolarità
a me invece cos'è accaduto dopo di
questa camicia e ho avuto la possibilità
di spiegare a tutto il mondo che che io
per lui realizzavo queste camicie con
queste grandi peculiarità male
realizzavo mare realizzavo per tutti
quindi la stampa ne ha parlato i
giornalisti hanno diffuso questa notizia
e ed io ho visto mi sono visto tanti
tanti clienti arrivare a ginosa
eccolo qui a ginosa e non estate ho
visto arrivare tanti clienti
tanti clienti tanta gente che arrivava
addirittura con la foto di quella
camicia li vecchi mi chiedeva
spiegazioni in estate arriva anche un
critico d'arte famoso che bazzica spesso
la zona di matera
spinto dalla curiosità della sua
fidanzata arriva a ginosa e quando il
primo giornalista gli fa una domanda
lui risponde gli chiedono ma perché lei
ea ginosa sono a ginosa perché sono
venuto ad incontrare uno stronzo che sta
facendo parlare di lui tutto il mondo
forse avete capito pure chi è comunque e
quindi
da quel giorno abbiamo visto arrivare
anche tanti tanti inglesi ecco poi
capirete perché vi dico che sono
arrivati anche questi inglesi allora poi
cos'è accaduto ecco cos'è accaduto che
dietro tutta questa pubblicità un giorno
eravamo alle prese con la preparazione
di pitti uomo ci arriva una telefonata
ci arriva una telefonata era la sartoria
della casa reale che ci annunciava che
il principe william avrebbe voluto
sposarsi con una nostra camicia in quel
momento emozione l'incredulità mai
passato di tutto e poi dalla mia mente è
passato tutto però ho subito iniziato a
concentrarmi sul da farsi e nello stesso
tempo purtroppo ero perseguitato dalla
stampa da dai media e dai giornali e
cosa dovevo fare ecco dovevo appunto
impegnarmi abbiamo realizzato sette
modelli li abbiamo inviati poi sono
diventati cinque alla fine ha scelto le
camicie le ultime due camici e
definitive che sono state quelle che lui
ha indossato per per il matrimonio
dopo di questo dopo questo momento qui
per me la vita è cambiata sotto
l'aspetto della tranquillità perché fino
ad allora vivevo in maniera molto
tranquilla
da quel giorno lì sono arrivati sono
arrivati fondi inglesi sono è arrivata
gente che voleva comprarla royalty
entrare in società proposte di tutti i
colori ed è arrivata una che mi ha fatto
riflettere tanto e chen e hurley è
arrivata una di un fondo inglese che
voleva acquistare il mio marchio pagando
pagando ma lo abbastanza caro però mi
precludeva la possibilità di continuare
a fare quello che faccio io non mi
nascondo che ci ho pensato ci ho pensato
per sei mesi
poi alla fine ho detto di no ho detto di
no perché non mi sembrava giusto non mi
sembrava giusto cancellare con una firma
con una firma tutto il sacrificio di mia
nonna tutto il sacrificio dei miei zii
dei miei genitori e poi quello che stavo
facendo io allora io ho detto di no
in cambio cosa ho fatto ho preferito
investire sul territorio
ho preferito investire sul territorio ed
ho acquistato un palazzo storico con
queste sembianze qui dove fare dove fare
una scuola dove fare una scuola dove
recuperare i vecchi mestieri dove
praticamente emettere a mettere in luce
tutto quello che manca un po al nostro
settore
quello che manca il nostro settore
perché ho fatto questo perché davanti a
una cifra del genere tu ti accorgi che
quando ti valutano
con quella cifra lì ti accorgi che poi
tutto tutto diventa superfluo ora la mia
soddisfazione personale quale quale
quale sarebbe la mia soddisfazione
personale sarebbe quella di dare una
giustificazione a quella rinuncia ma non
una giustificazione in senso di profitto
no una giustificazione nel senso di
completare questo progetto che io
continuo a chiamare sogno quindi quello
che io quello che io direi ecco il
messaggio che io vorrei lanciare è
proprio quello di dire ecco puntate
tantissimo sull'innovazione sulle
tecnologie su tutto però non
dimenticatevi mai della tradizione
perché senza la tradizione noi non
potremmo andare avanti grazie